I'm Roger Penrose I'm the mathematical
physicists I work at Oxford at the
unretired actually at Oxford and the
Andrew was building
[Music]
so last year you released some research
with which suggested that our universe
is just one stage in a potentially
infinite cycle of cosmic extinction and
rebirth could you explain a little bit
about what evidence you found that made
you embrace a sequential universe model
rather than the Big Bang model one of
the main reasons that I took this view
that as I say the universe is a
succession of what I call eons each of
which begins with a Big Bang and ends
with the universe expanding indefinitely
in this sort of way exponential
expansion that we seem to see now I've
been troubled by something for many many
decades which is the second law of
thermodynamics which tells you that
things would get more and more random as
time goes on and this tells you that the
Big Bang ought to be very non-random and
one of the most striking pieces of
evidence for the existence of the Big
Bang is what's called the microwave
background this is radiation coming
electromagnetic radiation coming from
all directions and one of the most
striking features of this radiation is
that it's in a maximum state of entropy
that is this completely random so it's a
sort of puzzle where does all this run
non-randomness come if we're just
presented with randomness and I came to
the conclusion that it has to be in
gravity that gravity has not been taking
part in this it's some one set is a very
low value of the entropy is very low
right at the beginning and that means
for gravity it means it's very uniform
so this is a huge puzzle why was gravity
behaving differently from other things
and I worried about this for a long time
I'm thinking that some kind of quantum
gravity would have to be a very time
asymmetrical theory and that didn't work
very well until I hit on this idea but
the very remote expansion this
exponential expansion
expands it gets colder and colder and
colder and more less and less dense and
black holes meaning most important
things around eventually evaporate away
by walking evaporation there's just
terms in prevention in terms of
radiation there's nothing left except
it's all spread out now the argument is
that when matter is all spread out like
this and it's only photons so it's
mainly photons that's as particles which
don't have any mass they have no way of
telling how big they are so it's a
mathematical thing but when you don't
have any mass big and small are
equivalent so the remote future the
universe sort of forgets how big it is
not a crazy idea of course but that's
the concept
it doesn't really know how big it is and
what about the Big Bang you see the Big
Bang is really the opposite it's really
hot and very dense and everything like
that and you think what could be more
different but when you look at it
carefully you see the very hot particles
running around because they're moving
around so fast
whatever mass they have it doesn't even
count the motion is the thing that
dominates the so they in fact have no
mass either
so both ends you have no mass therefore
neither end knows how big it is now
you've got to have some equations to
make sense of this but the idea is the
expanded previous iana sigh call it
becomes our a big bang now you have to
make equations to make that make sense
this is the part that people have great
trouble swallowing because it looks so
different but when you look at it from
the core the conformal point of view
that big and small you shapes make a lot
of difference but whether they're big
shapes or small shapes doesn't make a
difference and if you that means from
that perspective the remote future looks
like a big bang and it also has the
feature that all the gravitational
degrees of freedom are wiped out right
at the beginning so it explains this
puzzle I had of the second law of
thermodynamics and I don't think of any
other theory I've seen explains it there
are all sorts of ideas people have but
as far as I can see none of them work
which this one does at the expense of it
being a crazy idea but it's a crazy idea
which now seems to have some support
well are there were two kinds of support
one was I'm trying to think what's the
most energetic thing that might come
through from one Eon to the next and I
thought about black holes supermassive
black holes which collide with each
other and they send out these very
intense gravitational wave signals and
they can get through to the other and
there is some evidence that for the
signals that these would produce the
other thing was much more recent this is
this year when I guess we've had a year
it's really last year I suppose these
are the thing we call Hawking points I
collaborate mainly with some Polish
people and with Daniel and who does a
lot of the calculations he he's a Korean
who works in New York and they do the
hard work on this the idea is that the
black holes you see they eventually
evaporate away by the hawking of
apparition but all that radiation which
the black holes go into carry away the
entire mass of those black holes and the
biggest ones will be about as big as a
large cluster of galaxies so all that
mass is concentrated into this black
hole evaporates away and all that
radiation comes through into the next
eon and we have very very good evidence
that something like that is actually
having nobody's seen these you call them
some Hawking points or Hawking spots
these are little regions in the sky
about eight times the moon's diameter
sand not that small where the
temperature is raised by about 15 times
and that we see it's very strong
evidence these things are really there
so what kind of evidence did you use do
it was it telescopes or computer
assimilated these are looking at the
microwave background and these are the
two satellites which went out one of
them was called the W Maps satellite
and the newer one is called the Planck
satellite and we look first at the
Planck satellite data now the data looks
at all different directions it looks how
what's the intensity of that radiation
in all directions and so it's in the
maps that they produce so you get the
maps from the satellites and then it's a
matter of doing statistical analysis on
and there's this some mass theory to
heat that the other the universe would
actually die out because of lack of
energy or because of heat how would
there be a heat wave of the universe
before we reach the Eon when the
universe would collapse according to
notice you see the picture is that as
the universe expands it gets colder and
colder and colder it doesn't reek
elapsed you see many people have
produced theories where the universe
gets to a certain stage and it comes
back that's not the case here this is
the only model I know which doesn't do
that
it's a crazy model you see you think
well it gets it is going to get small
it's got to collapse but the picture is
that when it gets bigger and bigger and
there's nothing around which has any way
of telling how big it is it's the same
as being small and that's a difficult
idea to to appreciate it's the same as
being small and it has also effect that
big and cold is equivalent to small and
hot so you get a very very hot Big Bang
coming about as being the same physics
that's the part that's definitely hard
to understand and clearly that's why
people are having trouble with the
theory but if you write the mathematics
now you see that that they're sort of
equivalent when you don't have mass
around to give you a scale then these
two states are really very much similar
in fact the same as each other is the
argument the remote future with this
very spread out universe very cold very
rarefied is physically equivalent to
early very early stage of a Big Bang
what
the geometrical implications of this
theory well it's a kind of geometry
which is called conformal geometry and
it has been studied
you see people know of Euclidean
geometry you have triangles and you've
got lengths of size and all that but
with a conformal Drummond geometry a big
triangle and a little triangle a
completely equivalent and you could
there's some very nice pictures which I
like to use due to the Dutch artist MC
Escher and he had some nice things which
he called circle limits with angels and
devils all interlocking and it looks as
though they're getting smaller and
smaller as they get to the edge but for
them for the geometry that the angels
and devils are respecting it's all the
same the geometry right up to the edge
is the same as in the middle and the
edge represents infinity so it's the
same kind of picture see the infinity
that we are going to reach in the future
is really like the boundary of one of
these Esha pictures and you can imagine
going stepping outside to see what's on
the other side and what's on the other
side there's a big bang of the next day
on so there was one before us
it's remote future became a big bang our
remote future will become the big bang
of another year
so on both directions that's the picture
what was the reaction you got to this
this theory the support and the
skepticism I think the huge amount of
skepticism we has an awful lot of
trouble getting papers accepted and they
just don't believe it I guess even with
this verse there's no very strong
evidence there Hawking points the
evidence is about ninety nine point nine
eight percent confidence that is to say
it could be random but the chances
against that on nine nine nine eight to
200 so how do we imagine infinity then
it's like this kind of infinitely
expandable universe is the same as the
small things you you can describe
infinity you see this was a trick which
I used to use a long time ago when I was
looking at general relativity looking at
gravitational waves and how do you
define the energy in the waves and that
sort of thing and difficult problem
because the difficult problem because in
relativity you don't have a clearly
defined notion of energy this is I think
one of the troubles people had an
accepting that theory in the first place
but when you go out to infinity you see
what's radiation when it goes out and
hours and hours and out and it just
keeps going so where does it go well out
to infinity so the idea that I had was
to use one of these conformal maps which
squashers infinity down and then you can
see it it's just the boundary to the
space and then you can do your
calculations on that boundary and it's
much easier see if you if you've got
infinite you've got to do complicated
things taking limits and goodness knows
what and I've been like doing it that
way
I must refer to having a geometrical
picture when you squash infinity down as
in those Escher pictures squash it down
until it becomes finite boundary and
then you can imagine going through the
boundary then the other side and I kept
thinking you know gravitational waves or
electromagnetic waves there's no mass
things without mass they don't even
realize infinity is there they just
could go straight through if there was
anywhere to go you see so the idea here
is that there is somewhere to go and
where it goes is the Big Bang of the
next you know and it works extremely
well remarkably so what do you think it
takes until your skeptics are going to
be convinced it'll take oh I have no
idea I haven't I used to be much more
optimistic that people would pay too
you see we I had a paper with an
Armenian colleague we published in
European Journal and some polish
colleagues of mine had theirs published
in the Royal Society eventually
published after many many complaints
from referees and goodness they finally
got published and Christophe asked me
you see what sort of attention do you
have I guess it's zero so I asked him
what about you zero it's not as there
people say oh this is a load of rubbish
this is completely wrong for this reason
that reason that's just silence eerie
sort of silence is that because it's
just too shocking and they can't take it
or is it because everyone's so concerned
with their own theory that they aren't
open to like changes of kind of paradigm
well we'll have to see whether this
these new talking points we've taken a
lot of care to make it sort of
observational you see these things are
things we see and then there's
explanation well from my point of view
this conform exactly because mark does
actually predict these things but we
have to they've got to explain them and
they go against inflation it's very hard
to see how the current view of cosmic
inflation which is supposed to take in
place in the first fraction of a second
which is 1 over 32 digits a tiny
fraction of a second the whole universe
was supposed to expanded by a huge
amount it always seemed to me a pretty
crazy idea I mean just no more no less
crazy than mine as far as I can see but
it's it's sort of become accepted and
that's the standard view so if you're
going to upset that view you've got a
lot of people to turn around so how long
do we have until the next big bang then
well it's really infinity you see that's
that's the strange thing he says but
infinity to admit to a thing with no
mass isn't all that long see if it was
mass around where you see that the mass
there is a mass which sort of fades away
and you have to
so there was a there was an age you
could give to it but I haven't worked
that out it's not like it's not a
consistent age as everybody would agree
on so I think infinity is a better
answer because that's clear that's what
the Masters okay thank you my final
question will be related to your
interview with David David Malone
earlier when you said that you're not
opposed to free will and I was wondering
what that means to you on a scientific
level but also what it means to you on a
personal level well I've always been
troubled by free we went over the other
and there are experiments people do
which show that some part of them you
try to make a conscious choice about
something and there's some evidence of a
buildup of signals which tells you that
some part of the brain knew which choice
you were going to make but all these
things not what you'd use free well for
you see it's not quite particularly
because I had experiences when I was
young you see let me give you this
my younger brother used to there's this
game scissors and paper stone you know
that way and there are three things you
do added the scissors or the paper or
the stone on you and you don't reveal it
until the last minute and he used to
wallop me at this game consistently and
I thought I was using free will you see
to decide which I'm going to do how does
he know you know is it some mystery
predicting the future or something so
what I did I went to a table of
logarithms you know it's only about
seven or something he was spending about
five I can't remember and I used the
table of logarithms and I just worked it
out you know seven means Stone eight
means scissors or whatever it was and
all the way through you see so I take
these digits and I would play this game
reading off the digits and then I broke
even so it was as though my free will
was not really much of a free will you
see I was just doing which sort of came
easily to me at the moment and that kind
of thing
okay maybe you can make predictions
about what people are gonna guess next
and it's not really a free will is
freewill for a purpose you're doing
something because it means something not
just because it's a random choice so but
I I don't know I will always be in two
minds about that and you see physics you
might think well it's all determined and
so what you do now is determined by what
happened yesterday if you knew all the
details of how all the particles are
moving but this isn't quite true as
things go because you have this curious
thing within quantum mechanics you have
the collapse of the wavefunction that
the Schrodinger equation chugs along and
says what's going to happen suddenly it
doesn't it's something that's it jumps
to this or that and people usually talk
this and talk about this in terms of
measurements my view is that it's
happening all the time and you have just
lots of particles and when they get up
to a certain mass level then it does one
thing or another and whenever those
choices are made you see Stuart Hameroff
and I have built up this idea about
consciousness and we consider that
consciousness comes about when these
collapse wavefunction things happen now
the question is does it collapse in a
way which is random that's the that's
the way physics works now you consider
it to be quite random
well if it's maybe entangled with all
sorts of other things and the decision
about what it makes this or that has
some kind of content to it some mental
content which is not altogether random
and that would be where the freewill
plays its role so
you know maybe that's controlled by some
deterministic laws which go deep within
the laws we know now or is there some
actual freedom you know what happens in
the operation of the universe
I'm not making any sitting on one side
or the other here it just seems to me
look quite appealing that there is
something in a choice which is not
actually determined by the other laws of
physics and it's it's something more
much more subtle than than being random
it would have to be something which has
a God goes beyond computation and that's
what I claim is involved when we make
conscious choices but whether it's how
free it is I don't know I wouldn't like
to make a strong claim on that but this
room there's room for some kind of a
thing that you might call freewill there
yes you just never stop well there's so
many interesting things going on you
know I'd be quite happy to go and sit
and watch the television or something
but there are so many ideas like this
see see see the conformal circular
cosmology which you know this is only
just a year old that's basic me talking
points and that's it was something quite
new
I had worried about it before but I just
thought I couldn't face it in a way
because it's quite different you see the
whole big black holes hang around for
ages and ages and it is a very big ones
you have to wait for something like a
google yes that is one with a hundred
zeros yes where is everything else
interesting is long gone eight years ago
and these black holes are just sitting
there gradually gradually very very
slowly evaporating away by Hawking
evaporation so I'm accepting all that I
think that's correct yeah we do that
right away
and it would take something like 10 100
years but the big really big what maybe
longer because there's some really
walking ones that we'd end up
used huge galactic clusters most of it
going into a black black hole and I have
no idea how they were long but last they
were long long they would last but this
is very exciting and this is just new
stuff and where they're worried about it
before when when we Christophe Meisner
my colleague polish colleague said well
look we seem to see these very strong
signals she we originally they were
looking for the other signals more the
collisions between black hole signals
that but then he said look there's a
much stronger signal feasel of us not
maybe they're the Hawking points it's
thick because that's what you would
expect that the radiation would be
concentrated it's a really huge
explosion right in the middle of the Big
Bang all right you see current theory
says inflation takes place but I can't
have inflation in my skin it would ruin
it so there's a sort of inflation which
was the exponential expansion of the eon
prior to our so you look back it looks
rather like an inflationary period but
it's not before not after the Big Bang
it's before it and right in that final
stage the Big Bang would not it's pretty
uniform but they're little spots in it
where these Hawking points are which is
completely crazy and you should be able
to see I'm not sure how many but we see
about 30 of them let's say we see five
which are very well established because
receiving in both the W map and the
Planck data they're completely different
satellites and they both see them in
exactly the same places so the evidence
for them is pretty convincing now maybe
there are some inflationary arguments
somebody will produce it's going to be
something quite new it can't be in the
theory they have now but they're
predicted by this theory
I didn't kind of face up to the
prediction but yeah that's what you'd
expect you've got this points
much stronger sources of radiation these
individual points and then do you have
to work on this more oh are you moving
close to the next radical theory well
there are other things going on too
because there's twister theory now you
see that's I don't usually talk about it
in interviews because it's hard to
explain but that's an idea which I had a
lot of people working on when I was at
my graduate students had a lot of
graduate students and many of them work
on Twista theory which gives a different
different point of view how hard to do
view physics if you like see usually we
think of space time when space is 3
dimensions and then time is another one
so you've got this space time which is a
four dimensional structure and the basic
thing it's made of are these little
points we call them events you see no no
dimension in space no dimension in time
the but you see like that those are the
points in space-time of events now you
see you twist a theory that's not the
basic structure the basic thing is
basically but something like a photon
it's it goes along with the speed of
light and you can identify the points
because you have a family of them going
through that point it's sort of it's a
kind of geometry which turns the
ordinary way of looking at physics
inside out some things are more
difficult to do something is a lot
easier to do and what's a lot easier is
to describe feels like the Maxwell feel
for radiation the gravitational field in
fact gravitational field well there's a
story here you see photons can spin
left-handed or right-handed and you can
describe the wave function of a
left-handed or right-handed one and
usually you add them together because
they both spins combined together to
give you the linear polarization so
things you know polarized glasses you
have they let the light through one way
and not the other way and these and you
add to what right-handed and left-handed
together to get the linear polarized
then they're different ways of doing it
anyway that's the way photons work now
we see in twister theory it's very
peculiar
you have a two different formula one
which works for the right
then one which works for the left hand
and for the gravitons that is the
particle of gravity if you like again
you do this but you see with gravity you
want to make it fit in with Einstein's
theory so change your space spacetime is
changed by the gravity and then you find
you can do it and you can do it for the
left-handed ones but not for the
right-handed ones and this was a great
puzzle to me because what twister
theories got a twist to it so it's left
analyze are not quite the same in the
theory and you could do the left-handed
ones are not the right-handed ones and I
used to call this the googley problem
because in cricket
you see a ball a cricket ball and if it
spins what's the thing called a leg
break then if it spins left-handed
that's a leg break if you're very clever
many people can do it you can make it
spin looking as though it's got
left-handed but actually spins
right-handed and that's what's called a
googly so we call this the googly
problem because you're trying to get the
right-handed graviton in the framework
which does the left-handed one and that
was a stumbling block which took about
40 years and only fairly recently I had
an idea with some help from Michael
attea who have got ideas from write
often and I had sort of part of the idea
and I can quite understand the other
part which he explained and even then it
took another five he has to make it work
but I think it works so this is a way of
describing physics in this unusual way
and if you can spin both the writing
like that after you can do also there
the particle interactions the strong
interactions and the weak interactions
and you can put the lot right and the
left together and I haven't done any of
this but it's a potential way of looking
at physics in a completely different way
well some of its being looked at already
people people have picked up on twister
theory but not on this latest idea they
use it for scattering problems the
massless particles and things
but not to the extent that this would be
a global theory which should be able to
translate physics into this other
language and it has sort of features
which I appeal to me very much
one of them is the use of complex
numbers you see usually people think of
numbers are the integers 1 2 3 4
fractions which are 7 over 5 or whatever
it is or real numbers which you write by
decimal which goes off to infinity so
you tend to think of physics in terms of
real numbers they're called real numbers
they're not real in the ordinary sense
of real but they're real but they're no
more real than some other kinds of
numbers but the things called imaginary
numbers or complex numbers are things
were you allowed to have take the square
root of minus 1 and that's the key thing
you allowed to have a thing you call I
and that's the square root of minus 1
once you put that into it you have a
whole new but not that new it was many
centuries ago when the idea was
introduced but it's a whole different
way of looking at the world and the
thing about it is quantum mechanics
already looks at the world that way
quantum mechanics the states in quantum
mechanics involve these complex numbers
so the idea is that you bring that kind
of complex number geometry into the real
world in the classical world and it's
somehow the quantum the classic will get
all mixed up and it's a different way of
looking at things and there's very
beautiful mathematics in the complex
world if you like which you don't see in
the real world and it's and it's
something which when I was an undergrad
and mathematics undergraduate
I was absolutely stunned by the magic
there is in these complex complex number
means got a real number and imagine your
number together in the same number and
the algebra and the analysis and all
that stuff and the geometry of these
numbers has an elegance which you don't
see in the real number geometry so it
always struck me as you know wouldn't it
be nice if somehow that was what
governed the world and that's what
twister theory does it gives you a
complex number picture real and
imaginary together picture of the world
which involves quantum ideas as well as
classical ones but the new idea where
the googley problem seems to be solved I
haven't had a chance to look at it very
seriously that's your next challenge yes
the next problem yes when I give up on
cosmology well I don't do the birth it
was that there's so many new things in
the cosmology that need to be thought
about well you see they there's going to
be a talk tomorrow I guess on what's
called the invisible universe remember
watch this the universe is there
something that's to do with the thing
called the people called dark energy and
I call it Einsteins cosmological
constant he introduced this term
admittedly for the wrong reason
in 1917 he introduces and then took it
back because he didn't like it it was
the wrong reason but it's there
we find it is there and it's absolutely
crucial for my cosmology
it depends what infinity looks like you
see infinity is the wrong shape if you
don't have the cosmological constant
it's the right shape when you do have it
it's the same shape is a big bang it
takes a bit more explaining there but it
is essentially bang and that's because
the cosmological constants there and
there's the other kind of mysterious
invisible stuff which is called dark
matter now this scheme has a candidate
for what dark matter is in fact it's got
to be there the equations don't make
sense if there wasn't dark matter so
this is not the same as what they called
dark energy that matters stuff it's
stuff which you can see it gravitates
and galaxies you can see this most
galaxies are predominantly made of dark
matter
so you don't see it but it just
interacts gravitationally it doesn't
shine with light or anything else and
this scheme says you've got to have
stuff like that which doesn't show and
it doesn't interact any other way apart
from gravitation and it would decay with
a lifetime of something like 10 to the
11 years that is to say well what people
thought well a hundred thousand million
years long time but that's the decay
rate of these particles but you might be
able to detect them because there's a
predominant material in the universe and
so maybe the decay can be detected all
sorts of interesting questions that this
scheme raises observational things that
maybe people might look for so I'm not
going to give it up easily so maybe you
know could become a book
I had a book already which is called
cycles of time which didn't do terribly
well I think people for you know the
idea is too crazy and it's I don't know
it didn't sell as well as most of my
other books but I'm going to have to
bring up probably a new edition and it's
completely changed because all the
experiment all the observations none of
those were in the book and now we've got
only both kinds of observations the
black hole collisions which is pretty
good evidence for and the Hawking points
much bigger evidence for so I think that
if people don't you know they're gonna
have to think of other explanations for
these things they haven't bothered to do
so just yet
but the paper is not out yet on the
talking points we had an earlier version
which was rejected by Physical Review
Letters but we have a much better
version knowledge I hope so do you do
you get a sense that like you have stuck
to a lot of course of the same questions
throughout your career and like you get
a question and then you come back to it
yes he decades later I think I guess I'm
awfully stubborn that's what you're
trying to say I know I don't give up on
these things that's true
no like me no well the second law thing
the second or philatelic see where it
comes from a chair had to change my mind
at one you know seriously changed my
mind about that was it difficult
psychologically no it wasn't that
difficult because I didn't really see
what to do with the older I yes
well there were two changes of mind well
if you like it's the same part the same
thing I mean the big cosmic law the the
exactly call model conformal cycle as
long as you see it says that the Big
Bang was not the beginning whereas I had
these theorems well Stephen Hawking I
had the theorem about black holes so
when they collapsed you've got to have a
singular point in the middle I was
thinking a place where you think us go
wrong and you can't extend the solution
and you go back in time when you get to
the Big Bang and then Stephen Hawking
did most of that stuff to show that
these kinds of theorems extend to the
Big Bang - so that's the beginning and
you can't get through it but then you
see I have a different view it's because
of the conformal picture you see we were
doing it not looking at that way so did
you you don't it's a long story but you
see this it's really an evolution which
is initiated because we had these
singularity theorems I mean as I say I
have one with the black hole Stephen had
one with cosmology then we got together
and had a combined theorem which really
proved all the others but all the time
there is this worry that although that
was sort of the same ones in the future
where things go singular in the future
and the others where they go singular in
the past but there if in detail there
mattingly utterly different and this is
where the second law of thermodynamics
comes in the Big Bang is all very smooth
you think of it as a horrendous violent
thing but it's extremely
the whole and you don't get that from
inflation it's it's something which is
there in the beginning other ones in the
singularities in black holes an
incredible mess I don't know what they
look like there's some Russians who have
some ideas about that maybe they're
right but it's whatever it is they're
completely different absolutely
different and I used to think well
they've got to be quantum gravity
quantum gravity is how you get rather
singularities that's what everybody
thought that's what I thought and then I
thought well they're so completely
different it's got to be a theory which
is quite different in the future from in
the past time asymmetric theory and
that's horrible if you if you know about
quantum mechanics and quantum field
theory things like that it's it's
horrible
so this conformal scheme says it's
different it's not quantum gravity it's
some conformal trickery seeing physics
upside down it's one of the reasons to
people don't take me seriously you see
because they said no we know Big Bang
has got to be kind of gravity and so on
okay so this idea was not original there
a well-known physicist called minutes ya
know Gabrielle availability ah no and a
colleague produced a model a bit like my
cyclic one with a pre Big Bang and
compression was something which happened
before the Big Bang
so they had a model a bit like that not
in detail very different but it had some
of those ideas already
so you've got a good crowd outside like
nice people
well I think people pay attention but
the experts it takes it's difficult to
turn people around you see because
they've where you see I was a conference
in Poland not in Warsaw it was in
another place forget the name of it now
and there were lectures on various
things and there was a lecture given by
a young chap Polish chap which was a
having a very good lecture and it was
about in flow you turn off inflation you
see inflation is this enormous expansion
supposed to happen and then he's
supposed to turn off and it's the they
have ways of making you do that and it's
called the graceful exit it's got to
turn off in just a waitress doesn't
cause chaos you see there's a graceful
exit and he was talking about there that
and had all sorts of problems to do with
particle physics which I had never heard
of all sorts of new problems that it
raised and and he has some way of
getting around them managed at the end
and at dinner afterwards I was sitting
obviously at dinner
that was a very nice talk you know I
really very clear I appreciate that but
don't you sometimes get the feeling with
inflation is something easy for you and
he looked at me and he said all the time
you're working so hard at these things
to get it to work to make it work so why
do you think scientists or physicists
thing in this particular case I'm also
resistant to new theories I think I
would tend to be conservative in the way
they don't I don't know if that means
anything but no I think part of it is
cosmology is a big trap for nothing
nutcases you see there are many many
nasty theories which I think inflation
is a bit know but you see it's got lots
of clearly they're trying to do serious
science so that I shouldn't call it put
it in that category but there are a lot
of theories which are completely off the
wall and so you know if you're gonna
have to look up all those one after the
other you wouldn't be able to spend your
time doing anything serious I don't know
if that can't be a real explanation
because whatever they think of me
Kristof nice in there as well he's
really a particle physicist this is the
my main colleague in Warsaw and he's a
really good physicist really appreciate
it he's a particle physicist mainly but
then he sort of went off into this area
so I'm sure he's respected so I'm not
sure I don't I think it's just that the
idea takes getting used to
it's I mean there a lot of other ideas
we've seen much crazier than this you
see inflation leads you into these
bubble universes you see there could be
inflation taking here and it's just the
probability of it happening there it's
very very tiny the argument goes but it
might and so this point would explain if
later you see and there are these things
called internal inflation and they're
pretty uh Turley crazy really in my view
but you can see why they're driven to
these ideas because they're trying to
solve this second law problem and how do
you have an initial state which is
smooth enough to inflate and to me
that's completely wrong way of looking
at it but they you can see there's a
thread of logic in what they're doing
and I can see why they go in certain
directions even though those directions
seem to be much crazier than anything I
say but today my guess mine son crazy
that's right like I used to give
lectures on this calling it I called it
crazy outrageous you see and I call it
crazy meaning because they've got one to
get in there first before other people
said it you see actually in the early
days I would have given it about fifty
percent chance of being right even
though it was quite crazy but it's so
it's all that this problems that I've
been worrying about and then when the
observations came along I gave it good
good deal more than 50 percent
many other people accept me seriously so
what's the percentage when I say my
percentages now yeah well if I take the
actual examples of national figures it's
99.99 point nine eight eight percent
confidence that's in the paper that's in
the paper these signals because it might
not be inflate it might not be a CCC it
might be something else so what that
99.98% is says is that these signals are
genuine so if the signals are genuine
it's pretty hard is greater than average
inflation because you've got to have
them at the graceful exit point they've
got to be just when inflation is turning
off and suddenly bang it's got to be
like that
okay maybe they'll think of a way it
does that and it wouldn't really pass
them there will be inflationary versions
of this where the Hawking points are
talking points they're explosions and
the Big Bang I don't know explosions in
the graceful exit
don't ask me thank you so much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you